hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast i'm your host sean
carroll
in fact welcome to a special [ __ ]
edition
of the mindscape podcast now i know what
you're thinking there's probably plenty
of other episodes of mindscape which
qualify as [ __ ]
but this is not supposed to be a
description of the episode as a
description of what the episode is about
i apologize for anyone who finds the
language a little bit
uh colorful or spicy but [ __ ] has
become a technical term
in philosophy ever since the publication
in 2005
of on [ __ ] by harry frankfurt the
idea was supposed to be that [ __ ] is
different than lying in lying
you know that there's some truth and
you're telling the opposite of it
whereas in [ __ ] it's not not that
you're trying to tell untruths just that
you don't care
what the truth is you have something
that you want people to believe and
that's what you're going to try
to make them do so today's guest carl
bergstrom
is a biologist at the university of
washington who studies the role of
information in biology not especially
information in some highbrow information
theory sense although there
is that but how organisms use
information how organisms
share information with each other and
sometimes information that is not
true basically even crustaceans and
birds can [ __ ] each other in the
correct circumstances
so this naturally led him to study the
flow of information
in social networks among human beings
and now it's made him an expert in the
kobit 19
era of the amount of [ __ ] that we're
hearing over social media
and even over respectable news
organizations about what this pandemic
is doing to us
he's perfectly situated to talk about
this because carl and his colleague evan
west have been teaching a course that is
now
turned in to a published book called
calling [ __ ]
the art of skepticism in a data-driven
world
it's especially about how we can use
charts and graphs and numbers and data
to make a case that is basically
[ __ ] one of the features of the
modern
internet highly interconnected world is
that [ __ ] can both exist in new ways
and travel much more frequently and much
more effectively
so we need to understand both sides of
the equations both to
how to recognize [ __ ] when it's out
there in the world
and also how to prevent ourselves from
promulgating [ __ ] even if that's not
what we
mean to do so this is a fun episode you
will even see us do a little calculation
in real time and we'll get to both uh
big picture issues about the nature of
truth
but also directly relevant issues to the
big crisis that we're all facing right
now
so remember for those of you who don't
already know we have a patreon for the
mindscape podcast you can find a link to
it
at the website preposterousuniverse.com
podcast or just go right to patreon.com
m carroll and you can find it there we
have enormous gratitude to all the
patreon supporters
my endless thanks to you folks out there
you help support the podcast keep it
going keep it vibrant
and patreon supporters get ad free
episodes as well
as the ability to ask questions for the
monthly ask me anything episodes
so with that let's go
carl bergstrom welcome to the mindscape
podcast ah thanks a lot sean
so you have a book uh that has come out
on called calling [ __ ] that's the
that's the title is that right
that's right uh calling [ __ ] the art
of skepticism in a data-driven world
yeah we're gonna have to uh you know put
one of the caveats on this episode
saying that uh occasional bad language
will be used if [ __ ] counts as bad
language i suppose but
just so everyone knows i mean it's an
interesting journey you're you're a
biologist by training you've studied
uh how information comes into biology
and the role it plays
so i can kind of see how that segues
into [ __ ] but uh why don't you fill
us in on how exactly that happened
yeah it has been kind of a interesting
journey um i
started out trying to understand animal
communication and wrote about
animal communication a great deal as a
phd student and thinking about in
particular what keeps it honest
and why do uh animals tell each other
the truth because
if they lied all the time then they
wouldn't listen to each other but they
do listen to each other so
so what is it that keeps communication
honest and they're really elegant set of
mathematical models that
get at these kinds of questions and
they're paralleled by uh
really neat models in economic game
theory and
and so that was what i was really
interested in as a graduate student
from there i moved on and started
studying epidemiology actually
and did a postdoc in epidemiology
i started trying to understand how
new is kind of unfortunately prescient
but how
how new diseases emerge from from animal
hosts into the human population
and what happens then and what does that
spread look like and what can we do
about it and at the time i was really
thinking about things like
h5n1 avian flu and such and as i started
studying more and more about
epidemiology i was thinking a lot about
how things spread on networks
how do uh how do diseases in particular
uh spread through human contact networks
because if you just sort of treat a
disease as this mass action
situation where all the individuals are
just bumping into each other at random
you don't get a very good picture
of what disease spread actually looks
like and so i sort of took this detour
and spent five years thinking about
sort of the physics of networks and and
working on problems in
in network theory and as i started to
emerge from that
we had all of the kind of you know
current cultural
issues going on about uh spread of
misinformation and disinformation on
social networks and so that brought
together
you know some of these things i'd been
interested in for a very long time and
it sort of kept
working on it on a sort of back burner
way
about animal communication and about
honesty and dishonesty and economics of
information
and that brought that together with
really thinking trying to think clearly
about networks and
and how uh information travels uh or
anything else travels
along uh along networks and and you know
with the with the
um you know all the uh stress that was
given on the role of social media
uh with the spread of fake news and such
around the 2016 elections
um this became something i was really
very interested in and started trying to
work in that
area and but it must be a slightly weird
situation because
you've written a book with your
co-author gevin west and based on a
um course that you've been teaching at
the uw
on uh calling [ __ ] and presumably if
i know
how publishing works in between when you
handed in the manuscript and when it
came out
we got hit by a massive pandemic and
and you were sort of positioned to talk
about this in a useful way and now
you're at least a minor twitter
celebrity as the go-to place to
to have [ __ ] called on various takes
about covet 19.
well certainly has been something that
i've uh been trying to contribute during
the
during the the coveted pandemic yeah i
mean you're right we did hand in the
manuscript
before the before the pandemic broke out
and it sort of feels like in some ways
the book was written in a in a different
world in a different time and place
on the other hand it's amazingly
relevant to
everything that's going on right now and
you know i think you could rewrite the
entire book
uh swapping out every single example in
every chapter with something that's
happening around covet
um because it's it's just uh these
these are the sorts of uh problems that
we're dealing with whether
it's the misuse of inform of sort of
numbers and
and statistics to try to you know uh
basically push people around and
intimidate people
i've got all these mathematical models
and my models show this or my model show
that or here the figures
and you know figures don't lie which of
course they do
um or whether it's uh you know sort of
the dynamics of the way that uh
that social media leaves us vulnerable
to
disinformation being injected by foreign
actors i mean all of these things have
turned out to be major players during
the
during the current pandemic and so um
yeah it has been
uh interesting to to you know write this
book and then
and then find sort of immediate
application for it if
you will i mean there's no shortage of
applications of course but yes this is a
particularly
sharp example of some of these things i
mean but so
let's you know let's be scholarly about
this what do you mean
by the word [ __ ] because i'm sure
that some people have slightly different
ideas in mind
yeah so when i talk about [ __ ] i'm
really talking about uh
the the use of language or
figures or uh you know statistical
arguments
um that are intended to impress or
persuade or intimidate a viewer or
reader with a blatant disregard for
the actual truth of these arguments that
are being made
so harry frankfurt the philosopher who
wrote the
book on [ __ ] which was this sort of
uh originally a scholarly essay in an
obscure journal and then became a
surprise best-selling
little book through princeton university
press he defines [ __ ] as
uh as you know he distinguishes it from
lying by uh saying you know the liar
knows what she wants you to believe and
tries to lead you there away from the
truth and the bullshitter doesn't even
care
what you what about what the truth is
the bullshitter is just
simply trying to um you know
uh [ __ ] i mean trying to be often
trying to impress you
or persuade you or something like this
without even necessarily having a target
in mind
that's why i think you know i think of
an example i think of like you know i
think we all
uh had this experience in high school of
having to write an essay about
uh about you know something in in one of
our
uh you know humanities or social
sciences classes we didn't really
understand the reading that we had done
and
uh we've left it until too long and we
wanted to write something that would
make it look like we'd understood it we
didn't really give a damn what the
teacher believed about whatever we were
writing about
but we did want to try to make ourselves
look competent and that's kind of the
epitome of [ __ ] in harry frankfort's
sense
so it's less i mean maybe tell me this
is accurate or not it's less about
lying per se and more or less just not
caring if what you say is the truth or
not
you have some instrumental goal in mind
you're going to try to get there
by saying whatever it takes to get that
reaction in your audience
yeah i think that's exactly right um and
you know very often
that that goal i think is it
has something to do with uh you know
trying to impress someone or persuade
them of your own competence or
uh your own likability or whatever that
is
and so is this something that hooks into
your the biology research that you
that you mentioned i mean are there
evolutionary reasons
why we [ __ ] because clearly it's
it's prevalent
it's all over the place yeah that's
right i mean we talk about that in the
in the um leading chapter of the book
and
and we look at um we look at sort of
where you know where where did these
things have their origins and
and so it may be more along the lines of
true straight up deception
um more along the lines of lying than
along the lines of
you know harry frankfurt's type of
[ __ ] but uh you know [ __ ]
or or at least at least deception goes
way way back in the animal kingdom and
we have some we talk about some examples
uh they talk about somatopods these uh
crustaceans that
that have these very very powerful claws
and they
they threaten each other and they fight
with these powerful claws when they wave
the claws around
uh but uh they do something when they're
molting and
when they're molting their claws are you
know just basically a you know a
shelled lobster claw they're defenseless
and useless but they wave them around
anyway and try to intimidate each other
and it's often successful
it's this kind of deception we talk
about ravens and the way the ravens
actually have a
theory of mind and some of the
experiments that show that ravens can
can uh you know actually think about
what other birds see and what they might
be interpreting
and the way that they use that to try to
fool
um other con specifics and so of course
you know deception of that sort goes way
way back because
uh you know information can be uh
manipulating other organisms access to
information is a very good way to
manipulate their behavior and whether
that's done by
um you know manipulating that access to
information through a
communication channel that sort of
evolved for the purpose of communication
or whether it's done um you know through
something like camouflage
it can be a very effective way to you
know
you know communication channels in
general give you handles on other
people's behaviors
i tell you how do i get you to do
something like i
don't grab your arm and move it i talk
to you and convince you that that's the
thing that you want to do and so and so
this goes way way back and then
as we move toward humans uh you know we
what we have that's sort of
unique in humans are i believe unique in
humans is we have this sort of
infinitely expansible combinatorial
language that allows us to
you know create an infinite range of
meanings and and
and so forth and so we can we can talk
about and we can we can construct all of
these kinds of arguments and narratives
and entire
uh you know cognitive edifices
in the world uh that we can use to
influence what people do
and think and and so on and so we have
all of that and then we have a quite
well developed theory of mind
uh about one another so we can kind of
think about in advance how the stories
that i'm telling you are going to
manipulate your own belief states and
how that might
lead you to respond so when you you know
put all of this apparatus
together with the fact that uh you know
human incentives are
rarely perfectly aligned between any two
people that creates the
sort of uh you know setting in which
we'd have a bunch of lying and a bunch
of bullshitting as well
i guess it i'm going to guess that there
is some
game theoretic reason why when it comes
to communication between individuals
you usually want to be telling the truth
otherwise people won't believe anything
you say right there's some sort of
optimum mixture of [ __ ] you should
stick in there
to maximize the chance that you'll be
believed and also get what you want
yeah that's spot on and i mean we see
things like that i mean you see
something like this even in a poker game
right i mean it's uh that's what i'm
thinking of that's my general paradigm
for these issues okay
yeah exactly right so you so you see you
bluff some but you can't bluff
always and and and so otherwise people
will call your bluffs all the time
and uh it's the same when we interact in
person and then the you know the
frequency of the interaction
varies i mean if i if i do a single
appearance on your podcast i may
[ __ ] a lot more than if you're a
close colleague of mine that i deal with
on a daily basis that sort of thing
i wonder if uh i mean the the incentive
to put false ideas about the world
in the mind of other individuals is
pretty obvious to me
um what about putting false ideas about
the world into our own
minds i know that people have sort of
debated uh
how much we trick ourselves but clearly
we do in some sense or
either we trick ourselves or at least
we're not very good at always getting to
the right picture of the world yeah we
just you know of course there's a ton of
self-deception that goes on and i think
a lot of it
in my personal view is actually due to
uh you know
relatively ineffective application of
heuristics that we have
to various ways of interpreting the
information we have about the world
um you know there are certainly people
that argue that actually you have sort
of uh you know
adaptive or optimal self-deception where
you know you can actually
perform better at certain problems or
tasks if you
believe things that are false and and so
on
that to me clashes with an awful lot of
what
i think about uh you know our basic
principles and decision theory and so
i've not found those arguments
particularly persuasive but what is
completely clear is that we're all very
good at convincing of ourselves of
things that are wrong
and uh though i just don't think it's
necessarily optimal that we're doing so
well i mean that's interesting to me is
it a is it an open question or
considered an open question like is it
optimal to be as correct as possible
well if you're you know in in decision
theory you would certainly
um the other you know you you certainly
would you'll do
you know for whatever your objective
function is you'll do you'll do better
um if you have correct information than
if you have incorrect information making
just you'll say bayesian decisions based
on
based on that information um and
uh you know similarly in non-decision
theoretic context not in a game
theoretic context but if you're just
trying to make a decision that doesn't
impact anybody else more information
is always at least as good as as less
information and often
and usually better things get a little
bit more complicated when you move into
a game theoretic context uh you can
definitely have situations where
uh getting more information can hurt you
um
it's less obvious to me that getting
false information
um helps you in in those kinds of
situations
but uh uh you know that's
there are people that argue especially
that there are
you know constraints about what we can
do is say i'm not you know
humans can't bluff well so the only way
to be effective at bluffing is to
believe the thing you're bluffing about
for example would be one
argument so we've so we've evolved the
ability to self-deceive in order to be
better bluffers
um i don't understand why we didn't just
evolve to be good bluffers and believe
it
i mean i guess what it this is off topic
but it's just fascinating to me i mean
is there some sort of group selection
argument we could put down to say that
you know
for any individual they would be best
off getting the most accurate view of
the world possible but
within a species or within a community
if some people are wrong there's some
benefit to that like they act in crazy
ways that benefit the group
because of their adventurousness or
something well as an evolutionary
biologist i tend to be
pretty skeptical of group selection
arguments without
really really hard quantitative backing
because they just typically don't go
through
um you know the basic problem with the
group selection arguments or what george
williams
brought up a great evolutionary
biologist and he said well look
um sure that might be true that a group
that that has a mix of people
uh the ones that have crazy ideas and
ones that don't
does better than a group that all all
has sensible ideas
but uh within that group of people with
crazy
ideas and and reasonable ideas which
ones do better well the one the ones
with reasonable ideas do better and so
pretty soon you lose the you know the
genes for having crazy ideas go away to
massively oversimplify things and
pretend that they're jeans for having
crazy ideas but
um but you see what i'm trying to say
about about i do i do
and yet uh so many people have incorrect
ideas about the world so we have to work
to understand this um
good so back to [ __ ] then is there
okay is there like a
categorization is there a is there a
grand um aristotelian theory of kinds of
[ __ ]
you know i there have been it's
remarkable there's been quite a
detailed exploration of the
nature of [ __ ] and the philosophy
literature since frankfurt's original
paper
um there is not a taxonomy that i'm
completely happy with there are some
kind of fundamental debates that come
out in that
in that literature one of the really
important ones is uh
uh is is is [ __ ] in the in the mind
of the
speaker or the mind of the beholder in
other words says intent matter
um and uh so they're you know they're
arguments that go in both ways for harry
frankfurt intent very much matters
um and for uh for some other authors you
know it's like i mean it's a statement
it's on paper it's just the text it's
[ __ ] or it's not which is okay you
know
um so these are the kinds of things
people are carving up i don't know if
they're sort of a grand taxonomy of
of [ __ ] in any other sense
i mean i guess then the two strategic
questions are
uh how do we avoid being
bullshitted and then maybe the the
slightly naughtier one is how do we
become better bullshitters when it would
benefit us yeah i mean both of these are
are interesting valid
um questions and it's kind of been a
challenge too as we've been thinking
about so we've been teaching this course
calling [ __ ] since uh
since 2017 and one of the things we've
been kind of thinking about
is you know how do we um
you know make the world a better place
with this course instead of
just simply training people to be better
[ __ ] artists
um so let's see
to to get to the sort of first the the
first question how do we avoid
um being [ __ ] i think we're actually
quite good at
that for what i'd call old school
[ __ ] and old school [ __ ] is the
kind of weasel words that you'll hear
from you know company spokespeople
uh might be a sort of a political speech
it's sort of just taking rhetoric
and and words and it's maybe this notion
of paltering
um that uh that people use to kind of
you know bend the truth or or get around
the truth enough to have
you know plausible deniability or
diffuse away the
direct responsibility by using passive
voice and all of this and we're i think
we're pretty attuned to that we're good
at picking that kind of thing up
uh when people are bullshitting we know
it and and you know we wince and people
have a natural distaste for sort of
weaselwordery
and all of that um and what the book is
really about
is that there's this stuff that i call
new school [ __ ] and that comes
clad in the trappings of science and in
particular in the trappings of numbers
and statistics
and kind of figures and and machine
learning algorithms and all of that
and i think that we are more susceptible
to this because first of all it's a
relatively new thing the world's so much
more quantified than it was 20 years ago
for reasons we could talk about
um you know second of all i don't think
the education system is really doing as
much to train us to be uh uh tuned to
this kind of uh
quantitative [ __ ] that's that's out
there and third i think there's this
feeling that we have that numbers are
somehow
you know more real or objective than
words words or opinions
and they're kind of they're fuzzy and
numbers are these hard things that come
straight to nate from nature
and of course uh you know that's not
true and then uh
and even when it is true there's so much
flexibility in the way that people
present numbers and facts and figures
that they can
give you true numbers but make you feel
completely differently about them
depending on how they're presented
so that's really what we're trying to do
in the book is to say look um you know
we're assuming that you know
when when the um corporate spokesperson
is bullshitting their way out of
taking responsibility for something but
uh but
uh it's a lot harder when somebody comes
rolling in with a statistical analysis
and waves it in your face and you don't
quite you know
you've never learned that kind of uh
analysis or you don't remember what it
does if you have learned it and
you know then how can you challenge them
yeah i mean i guess i
i want to get to the quantitative stuff
because obviously that's it's
fascinating but
maybe i'm a little bit less optimistic
than you are about
the old school [ __ ] i mean for the
examples that come to mind are just
hugely grandiose claims from sketchy
sources
which in my experience people are really
willing to buy
um and as a physicist you know people on
the street come out
saying oh i've solved all of physics and
there's a remarkable number of people
who are like okay we should take that
seriously or
or recently just as we're recording this
uh the new york times had a story about
ufos being captured by the pentagon
and people are like oh we should
definitely pay attention to this
it is really interesting you know i i
this this i out
of just curiosity i went to a
heterodox science conference that was
held on the
campus of the university of washington
because essentially because the
university is a public
institution and anybody cannot use our
facilities
um and i was i was quite interested to
see what uh
what what uh was going on of course
every person there
had either um you know uh disproven
general relativity
or had uh you know unified it with
quantum theory
um and uh and and and
so it was very interesting there you
know they felt that there was this
conspiracy by
by by big science um to sort of to sort
of cover up the problems with uh
um with with modern uh astrophysics and
quantum theory and so on which was
interesting in its own right but the
thing that was
i think the most interesting to me was
that the rhetoric they used was
very much the uh many of the things that
we'd essentially try to teach our
students
in classes to be skeptical you know to
say you don't want to just
don't take this for granted you know ask
and somehow it was just this sort of
misapplication
of those principles which are quite
reasonable principles that
that had led people down the wrong path
you know coupled with the
various delusions of grandeur and and
deep misunderstandings about how science
works
um that that had led you to this place
so i see i see what you're saying
especially as a physicist how you would
uh
feel vulnerable to this you know it's
there's there's there's
there's there's nothing you know
glorious about figuring out
uh uh about you know reversing the uh
the
you know popular belief about the life
cycle of the three-toed
river salamander and so um these guys
don't come after that
but they sure come after you know grand
unified theories of physics and such
but i mean can you uh for our audience
members who might be
uh romantically tempted by these
theories is is there a
is it's i know it's it's difficult to
make everything
boil down to an algorithm but like are
there rules of thumb when we see a
scientific claim
outside our own area of expertise like
none of us
has an area of expertise all on all of
science right but
what are the warning signs that okay
maybe this is a little bit less
uh reliable than something else might be
i mean you know this is this is uh this
is
i mean i'm going to give you an answer
that people will immediately re you know
you know people contrarians will
immediately say as an appeal to
authority
but uh you know my my answer is uh
if somebody makes a particularly
particularly someone makes a really
shocking or extraordinary claim you want
to look at the uh
the venues in which that claim appears
and the and the credence that it's given
by
uh by people who are well thought of
in the field and um you know and and i
think the
so if somebody if you know if somebody
actually was able to mathematically show
that there were fundamental
contradictions in general relativity and
we should throw the whole thing out and
replace it with their new framework
uh you know we would expect this to
appear in uh you know
better be in physical review letters and
in science and better be in the
newspapers and you have top physicists
uh
you know taking it very very seriously
and to give you an example
i mean uh you know there are some people
say oh that you know
there's a cover-up they'd never they'd
never do that but of course people do
take these things very seriously and
when we had the cold
whole cold fusion story uh there were a
number of really good groups that that
investigated that in great detail even
though it seemed like a fairly
implausible
claim um because it's so damned
important if it turns out to be right
and it wasn't you know it wasn't
patently wrong on the surface even
though it did raise some major questions
that no one
you know had answers to at the time if
it had been true
so um you know i think one thing to do
is just basically look at the venues
look at who's
supporting this and uh and think that
look the the world changing ideas
uh may not come from um you know the
most important uh most prominent people
but they will be relatively quickly
embraced by some reasonable fraction
of serious scholars in that area and and
and
here i think it just helps enormously to
try to explain to people a little bit
more about how
about how the scientific community works
it's not like we all you know go to a
meeting and sit down and decide what
we're going to tell the public it's
it's this very uh you know oh my
goodness no
it's this very red and tooth and claw
world right where everybody's trying to
scramble their way to the top and
there's uh
you know enormous prestige and and so
forth to be had by uh
by getting in early on something that's
right and and disproving something else
and
you know so if somebody had really made
this major discovery
um you know that's a that and and you're
one of the first people to pick that up
that's
that's that completely makes your career
and and and people would
jump on that um so anyway i think that's
maybe might help with dealing you know
thinking about some of these sort of
contrarian
scientific claims no actually i think
that's a wonderful point probably the
best advice you can give i mean people
talk about the establishment or whatever
as if it's a monolithic thing but the
reality is
there's a bunch of people who are
competing with each other and they would
love to find
the new brilliant idea so if some
outsider scientist
comes up with it uh if it's at all
plausible someone's going to jump on
that i mean i
think it's a very good thing to point
out yeah absolutely i mean i think
that's the you know
and and if no one does jump on it then
then uh that that tells you something
right that's time yeah exactly
this this heterodox conference was very
interesting because the uh
one of the speakers there one of the
organizers actually said you know he was
talking about what they needed to do to
to move forward i mean these are people
that are passionately in love with
science by the way these are not
uh you know denial or anything like that
i mean they adore science and they want
to be
they want to be part of it uh but
they're talking about what they need to
do and the organizers said well
um you know one of the problems is when
we have our conference
um everybody's selling and nobody's
buying yeah
everyone comes in and they've got their
own personal theory and
and it's almost as if everyone knows
that no one else's theory is worth
taking seriously
um and and that's so different from what
science is right because when we go to a
meeting
um you know sure we're selling but but
we are buying i mean there just be no
point to go to
you know a major society meeting um if
you weren't there to buy so to speak
oh yeah yeah yeah no i mean i i dream
about you know small meetings with
wonderful people and
at which there are no talks and everyone
just sort of talks to each other and
here's what each other has to say but
pretty i guess i used to go to and i
now i don't go to anything i just log on
to zoom in the morning
so has uh so you so you you indicate the
idea that
um the quantitative era that we're in
now has sort of changed the nature of
[ __ ]
i imagine that's both in the kinds of
[ __ ] that we can get but
also in how we can spread it i mean what
are the new kinds of [ __ ]
that uh have arrived since we've started
to quantify the universe
so precisely yeah so i think um you know
i i think there's just been a
fundamental change in the last 20 years
about how
data and numerical arguments are
introduced into the public discourse uh
so you know if you look at newspaper
articles from the 1980s
say um you know when i was a in high
school
you would not see a whole lot of data
visualization you wouldn't see
you wouldn't see you know just a whole
lot of discussion of statistical uh
uh arguments if you did you just it
would just say you know oh the fed did
statistics and here's the
qualitative you know outcome or
something like this but you wouldn't go
into these kinds of details and you
wouldn't you wouldn't have
there's no such thing as data journalism
um and
and and we just simply didn't use uh
numbers to for persuasive purposes the
way we do now i think so much has
changed in the last 20 years
if we think about the availability of
data compared to what
what what was there even in the year
2000 i mean first of all we're all
tracking ourselves
uh physically in space with the cell
phones we have
then we're you know through the sort of
data exhaust we produce
uh you know with with companies you know
google knows what we want to know and
amazon knows what we want to read
and uh you know
uber knows where we want to go and uh
and
tinder knows who we want to go there
with and and all of this right so all of
this information is
is is out there we're creating you know
just unbelievable data sets within the
sort of a b testing that any of these
companies can do in real time
uh on their user interfaces means that
every single one of these companies
knows more about
psychology than you know been sort of
the
you know collective discoveries of the
entire psych community
at least about these you know very
specific things about what color buttons
do people click on and
and what kind of wording works well in
headlines um
and in fact not only do they know that
but they know that like tailored to each
of us individually because
so there's all of that data and then
there's all the environmental sensing
that's out there
um you know and then we have the
internet of things and so you know my
refrigerator
is telling google a tremendous amount
about you know how often i go to the
grocery store because once a week i
leave it open for
for 20 minutes when i load it in and
yeah my car down
so just all of this data that we live in
is
is a fundamentally new thing and we're
taking that on
i think in the way that we that we
make persuasive arguments about how the
world works and about what we should do
in the world and so when you look at
you know even on a news broadcast you
see a ton of
data visualization you know the new york
times has a large and extremely talented
data visualization team
a couple of dozen people that does these
amazing things
um and i see all of that has really been
a massive change
in the last 20 years i feel like our
education system hasn't really
adequately caught up to that
and is the biggest problem that people
misuse it or people don't know how to
use it when it comes to
you know making persuasive cases on the
basis of some data sets
i think that there's some of each um you
know i think there's
i mean you know there are
uh you know they're most i think you
know most of the people that
that are putting material out there in
say traditional media
are you know good actors at heart um
however we typically do have
perspectives and we try to
uh convey those perspectives as
powerfully as we can and
i think that's completely fine by the
way i mean this is the same thing in
science right it's like
you know part of why science actually
works well is as we've talked about it's
a somewhat adversarial
system it's you know i would love to
prove that you were wrong
and oh yeah and that sets up these nice
arguments where we each try to make our
case as well as possible and then the
universe can
adjudicate uh between us and and so
that's very so we do anyways we do the
same thing in the
in the media um and even if we don't
necessarily know
um you know all of the the black arts
of uh of manipulating data and the
stories that come out and
telling misleading stories out of data
we certainly
kind of you know get this get an
inclination as we're playing around with
ways to display things oh well you know
it sort of seems more
persuasive you know i want these numbers
to look really big so i'm not going to
write them down as percentages i'm going
to write them down as absolute numbers
because there's
330 million people in the u.s if i do
that
you know the numbers get big you know um
so you see these sorts of
you know arguments where someone says
you know you know a thousand uh
a thousand uh daca recipients have been
accused of crimes against americans
right and it sounds like this terrible
number and
and oh my gosh a thousand crimes and
then
you know what you're not you know what
you what you're not pointing out is that
that rate of uh
of being accused of crimes is you know
more than an order of magnitude lower
than american citizens for example
um and uh you know so we talk about
those kinds of examples in the book
um and and we see this you know uh i i i
you know some of this may be malicious
and deliberate and and a lot of it i
think is just
people that uh that are trying to make
their case as well as possible and kind
of you know
doing that however you know it
kind of uh you know stumbling into
some of these tricks if you will well
the example that you just mentioned i
think
i mean that is an example um of a more
general
trend tendency whatever you want to call
it uh do people
to not take either rates or fractions or
proportionalities
into account i mean i read a the thing
that really bugged me is i read an
article about
buffets and restaurants and you know how
they're going away and
it would just say like you know oh in
this town three people got sick at a
buffet but there was no comparison to
how many people
got sick from other ways or at non
buffets or anything like that i mean
is this an example of a general
principle that we should be
keeping in mind when we look at other
people's data yeah i mean we essentially
have a chapter on this in the book
um and uh you know so some of the things
that you described you know there are
these you know people choosing whether
to use percentages
uh you know you can use percentages to
to
um so if you have a if you have a really
big number but you have a really big
denominator and you want to make that
big number look small you could
report it as a percentage or vice versa
and you brought up another very
important thing which is that
numbers need to be presented in a way
that allow you to make useful
comparisons
and when numbers are presented in ways
that don't allow you to make useful
comparisons
that makes them almost by
their very nature [ __ ] uh because if
i just say you know hey look sean
um you know 123
people uh you know um
had a heart attack while listening to a
podcast last year i really need to stop
doing this
um right you you might think like oh
[ __ ] you know i
i need to rethink my whole life but but
you
but uh about your whole life but one one
little element of your life but in any
case
um uh you know but of course the right
thing to do would be to say well you
know how many hours or
how many hours did americans listen to
podcasts and how many
uh you know how many heart attacks do
people have an hour and so on
and cash that out because there's just
you know if i just give you a number you
can't you can't possibly make meaningful
comparisons and
and so i mean that actually that's i
mean this is really something we're
talking about a lot in the book is this
this
sort of use of sort of quantitative
shock and awe where you just
throw these numbers out there um and
because you've got them it's really hard
for somebody to come back and i you know
if i make a claim like that by the way i
have no idea whether it's you know
i'm off by two orders of magnitude in
either direction but uh
um but in any case if i make a claim
like that it's really hard for you to
respond right away because
you know unless you're super good at
fermi estimation which you may be
right um you know you're gonna you're
gonna you're gonna struggle to
to be able to come back and say you know
oh yeah well here
here is the right denominator and when
you do this division and here's the
comparator
and uh so you know one of the things
that we're really encouraging people to
do is when they're when they feel like
they're getting pushed around by numbers
like that
is to you know take a step back uh you
know if we talk a little bit about fermi
estimation and how you could sit down
and do that calculation
and uh and and figure out whether a
number like that should be
you know something that's frightening or
whether that's entirely to be expected
um etc or just or you know alternatively
just run a quick google search and work
something like that out that way
um maybe for the listeners you can fill
them in on uh what a fermi calculation
actually is
oh yeah so fermi calculations are is
just this notion of doing a
sort of you know back of the envelope uh
quick
estimation of the rough order of
magnitude sort of what power of 10
is a is a particular um quantity and
named after enrico fermi who was
very very successful very skilled at
this
and and i find it a very very uh useful
technique whenever i'm
confronted with uh with with these
various uh
you know um numerical claims uh
to to just see whether you know is this
even
um in the ballpark of plausible
um right and is and then also uh if it
is in the ballpark
of plausible is there anything i should
be surprised by
you know um yeah so you could sit down
and
you could you could say well people live
for roughly a hundred years there's a
certain number of people in the united
states they must be dying at a certain
rate
should i be surprised that people die
while listening to podcasts exactly yeah
yeah that's right
yeah and you try to do and you know what
we encourage for fermi estimation is
that you don't get sort of hung up
you know just to get it roughly right
you could you could do it uh you know
just use powers of ten
and so so i mean we can even do it we
can even do that one live and then you
can cut it out if it doesn't work but uh
you know so uh so so so what do you
think people live for a hundred years
i'll agree with you on that
um what fraction of americans
you know a tenth of americans are
podcast listeners shall we say
and and uh of these of these podcast
listeners
um you know the 10 hours a week
do you think they listen 10 hours a week
okay so uh
order dude yeah yeah order magnitude uh
uh 10 hours a week let's let's have them
uh let's
let's have them uh listen um
let's see yeah okay so so then so then
they've got uh
um you know then then you've got 500
hours of of listening
um a year and uh
i shouldn't be trying to do this live
the uh could make it 100 hours a year if
it's
the numbers would be easier yeah so you
can see i see you listen 100 hours a
year
and um and and so but of course off the
top of my head how many hours
in a year um well that's why it gets
hard right
right right right right exactly because
we don't live in a sensible
universe for years or a thousand days
long through metric this would all be
so much damn damn easier you know so
uh yeah uh let's leave this in
but now okay yes you can cut this one
out but you know 10 000 hours in a year
they're listening for 100 hours
um so you know there's a one in 100
chance
if somebody dies in a year that they're
listening to a podcast while they do it
um you know and now uh now you've got
300 million americans 330 million
uh 330 million americans so we're going
to have uh
you know well here here here here here
here your americans live you know lives
exactly a half a log between
between your powers of 10 which is
always unfortunate in doing these
calculations
but uh but you know so so let's
so let's say you've got uh um
let's let's say you've got three million
americans dying a year one in a hundred
of them is uh
is dying while listening to a podcast if
they're a podcast listener it's only one
in ten of those so one in a thousand of
the
of the three million americans that die
a year let's die listening to a podcast
so one in three thousand
uh uh uh so so you have about 3 000
podcast deaths
due to heart attack i don't think
podcast a year not all due to heart
attack and then we can say well you know
one in 10
americans dies to heart attack and we
get one in 300 and and
you know so it's the same order of
magnitude as the 123 that i threw at you
at the start
yeah i know that's pretty good yeah i
hope you'll cut that all out but uh
that's uh
but you really because i'm going to keep
it in there because i think this is
absolutely
it's fine yeah i mean it's a wonderful
you know i
i just did i'm doing these videos these
days on uh
some of the big ideas in science and
believe it or not i got
the periodic table dramatically wrong i
said the beryllium was the third element
rather than lithium and you know i got
some comments
saying like oh that was my favorite part
because you made a mistake i love it
yeah i mean yeah that's that's totally
true that's
seeing how the sausage is made is very
very useful it is useful actually
and it's kind of fun to do right i mean
it's just yeah and it's a demonstration
that it's doable like and it's also
you know there is the fact that your iq
gets cut in half when you stand
in front of a blackboard or or get on a
live podcast so
this is certainly true that's uh people
should cut slack for that
but you know so part of this is is uh
how we get the data and what we do
within our individual brains but i know
that you're interested in the sort of
ecosystem
questions as well and there are a lot of
journalists
or more broadly people sharing
information who are not trained who have
not taken your course
is there some realistic aspiration that
we can just
train up all the citizens in the country
or in the world
to think a little bit more carefully
about statistics and rates and things
like that
i think if we're going to keep using
social media i don't think we have an
alternative uh the thing about social
media right is that
we had this and we talked about this as
well in the second chapter of the book
about the way that sort of
uh the way that information uh
production
and distribution has changed uh you know
not only sort of the volume of
information and its rate but also what
kind of information is out there and so
there's been this there's this you know
fundamental change essentially for most
people in the 1990s where
where all of a sudden you go from having
you know the
you know basically you get you get you
know the internet plus digital type
setting and now everyone can create
professional level
content um yeah you know add the web on
top of that plus the acceptance of world
wide web you don't even have to know
latex and then
you uh you you add um you know
so then you're starting to get all this
you know new content and we were all
very excited about this in the 1990s
because it was going to bring all these
voices to the table that maybe hadn't
had the political and
social and economic capital to be there
and
and to some degree that promise has been
realized um
but what we also got of course is this
enormous glut of information
and we came to all these problems about
how do we sort through it and one of the
solutions that we've come to especially
given the sort of acceleration at which
you know about the rate at which this
information is is produced is
is through social media where uh we all
take on the role of becoming editors for
one another and so
all of a sudden i have this really
important role in determining what my
friends
read or you know given the amount of
time i'm spending on twitter these days
a lot of people have never met
and what what what what you know and
what they read
but but we're all doing this and so
we're all filtering information
in this way and we're all doing the
things that professional editors used to
do and one of the big problems is you
know we you know not only don't we have
the training but we also don't have the
same incentives
uh that professional editors do in terms
of you know protecting our reputation
and you know we may be trying to signal
something about our group identity by
sharing a
meme instead of like you know trying to
signal something about the truth and
uh but in any case because of because
we're
using a information exchange system
where we are all playing this role of
editors
um people have to i think if we're going
to have
you know reasonable information hygiene
out there in the world people have to
you know what we suggest in the class is
they have to learn to think more share
less right
and uh and and and
you know how to think carefully about
what they are sharing before they
before they share it and you know this
sort of as i see it there's kind of
three approaches you can take to this
problem in the social media universe i
mean you could try to throw technology
at it and
oh we're going to have ai that can
detect fake news and while that might
get you a deal with the vc i don't think
there's any chance you're going to be
able to actually make that happen
because the power of adversarial ai and
everything else
um you know even even if someone were
able to do it for the current
you know as things stood now it would be
easy to overcome
so on then you could try regulation and
you could you could try doing things
like many
places have of sort of criminalizing
misinformation and so on and
as a pretty strong advocate of of a
very broad
interpretation of first amendment rights
i don't like this solution
i would like to see some regulation over
the tech you know of the tech industry
to make sure that
that we have some control of individual
users of what we see
but other than that i you know i don't
want to
go down that road and the sort of the
third leg of the stool that i see there
is
is education and and that's the only one
that i think we can really stand on
is to help people understand better
how to parse the media environment that
we all live in now and
a big part of that is sort of media
literacy and and
and that kind of education but at the
same time as we move toward this
increasing
uh quantification of our world i think
this quantitative literacy becomes very
important as well
but i guess what i worry about with that
i mean i agree with everything you said
but um the pessimist in me says
well the biggest problem is not people
who want to get the truth but don't have
the quantitative
education to do it the people whose
incentives are to do something other
than get the truth you know to identify
with their tribe or whatever and
and media social media make that so much
easier
in some ways than it ever was before i
don't have a rebuttal to that i mean
we've slammed very very hard into that
during the uh during the covet crisis
and
and that's something that actually uh
we never really anticipated or saw
coming you know i spent the
20 aughts you know doing pandemic
planning work um
and while there were a lot of uh you
know debates
uh you know in the scientific community
and and in the political
uh setting about you know what role
should the government versus the
free market have in planning for rare
you know
health disasters and so on we all
assumed that if
something like this ever broke out
everyone would be on the same page
uh and we'd just try to get the get this
thing done
and instead of of course we find
ourselves in a world where the very
existence of the virus is a politicized
issue whether masked work politicized
does
hydroxychloroquine work politicized and
this is really bonkers because if you
sort of think about it
i mean there are a lot of things where
if i said oh hey you know sean there's
going to be this crisis
in two years here's what the crisis is
going to be uh some people are going to
want to do this response are they on the
left or the right
you'll say oh military intervention
they're on this side right if i said you
know hey sean there's going to be a
pandemic and some people are gonna want
hydroxychloroquine
you've got no way to tell me whether
that's gonna fall on the left or right
right this is just
no reason to politicize that it doesn't
make any sense but
it is this tribal allegiance that you're
talking about it is facilitated by
uh um you know by social media and it's
been an enormous problem
uh in our national response to to covet
because you get things like you know
people
refusing to wear masks simply
to signal uh their their
uh their tribal affiliations yeah i mean
it seems as if
i've never really thought about it in
these terms but it seems as if there's
some
um uh stew of interactions that spiral
you down
between number one the ability to
[ __ ] and
quantitatively in this uh data-driven
world we're in
number two the ability to spread the
[ __ ] through the social media
and number three the partisan or
identity affiliations that make your
allegiance to a certain statement
stronger than your allegiance to the
truth
and uh somehow we got to change the
incentive so that somehow people are
punished for
uh giving in to that yeah i think that's
you know i think
that is the sort of thing that that is
happening um you know
uh my colleague joe buck coleman and i
have sort of you know
not completely jokingly said that the
answer to the fermi paradox you know the
fact that there are no
you know we in fact we don't see
evidence of intelligent life anywhere
out there
is not that people invent nuclear
weapons it's they invent social media
um and it launches you exactly into that
uh
not people aliens but it launches you
exactly into that spiral that you're
that you're sort of describing and that
could be an existential threat we have a
somewhat more serious paper that we're
working on about
we call human collective decision making
as a crisis discipline
you know the idea is is again this this
same sort of thing it's like once you
network people and you have all these
tribal affiliations
um you know what happens what happens to
the way that information flows what
happens to the ability to have an
informed electorate
um and these become things that you know
we were working on this before covet and
and and thinking this was going to be a
real problem and you know it's one of
those papers where
now everyone doesn't it doesn't seem
nearly as prescient when you publish it
after it's already happened
well we shouldn't blame put too much
blame on uh facebook and twitter
at all i mean you also mentioned things
like ted talks or
self-help books or there's there's
pre-existing set of ways
that we [ __ ] ourselves and each
other
that's for sure you know there's you
know it's it's by no means the uh
you know sole domain of uh of of social
media
i think that's you know i keep coming
back to this partly because of this
interest i talked to you about at the
start about
uh the way that information spreads
through networks and i find that so
fascinating it's really
the the patterns of information flow are
so fundamentally different from these
highly centralized patterns where
you know you have the the ted foundation
or whatever it is that you know hand
picks uh
some um you know people to groom into
media stars and then puts them up and
and and you know teaches them how to
give a 10-minute talk that
that uh starts with a a problem and and
uh
you know ends up with this techno
optimist solution and
has three jokes along the way at minute
two seven and nine
and and so on and then uh uh and then
you know broadcast that in the central
broadcast
fashion and then it's just absolutely so
different from the dynamics of what we
see playing out on the internet uh
when when you know which can be a really
enormous and powerful scale as we see
things like the
dreadful information around the pandemic
video and so on
um taking off so understanding those
dynamics are so fascinating to me that's
why i keep coming back to it but
absolutely i mean the seeds of all of
this
uh you know pre-date social media there
have always been
uh um you know there have always been
charlatans and hucksters and
and all of this and a lot of that takes
the form i think of
of [ __ ] rather than of just outright
lying because a lot of them just want to
impress you and and make you think wow
that that person's really smart that
person's a thought leader that you know
whatever well yeah the thought leader
terminology is a good one because it
once again comes back to the
incentive structures i mean i know that
there has been a lot of discussion in
recent years on the role of public
intellectuals
and one claim is that we don't have
public intellectuals anymore all we have
are thought leaders and the difference
being that
the thought leaders are a little bit uh
more beholden
to you know certain uh patrons who will
pay them to say optimistic things about
technology or
whatever and it's a little bit less
rigorous and scholarly than the public
intellectual model
yeah that's very interesting i think
that that you know i
i i've just heard it now but i buy it uh
we
on it first on a first on a first
thought yeah also i guess there's not
much intellectual about a thought leader
is the other
um well yeah i mean i think i don't know
what the uh
origin of the phrase thought leader was
it might be something that was
originally very sincere and now has been
uh given so much irony layered on top
but uh
it might be it was dresner it was it was
who made that who was it sorry
daniel dresner maybe okay the place i
know it was
you know in the in the 90s um this was
uh
this was the term for uh that that so
basically it was what the pharma
companies used to uh
to influence what doctors do uh
influence their prescribing practices
it's too expensive to get things
to get uh on label uses approved through
fda but what you can do is you can have
people
uh give talks at meetings about
off-label uses which then
doctors have the right to do and thought
leaders are the people that people look
up to
who are who would you know be able to
give a compelling talk in front of an
audience of
say 5 000 or 10 000 at a major medical
conference and so
a thought leader was uh precisely the
person that pharma would seek out to
give a talk about off-label use of their
product but that's interesting because
that so if
to the sense that that's true built into
the idea was the idea that it was
more for signaling purposes than for
finding truth purposes
absolutely i mean that was the uh you
know and i don't know if that's the
original origin that's just my first
place i encountered it
maybe i i do want you to have a chance
to say a little bit more
uh about solutions to the
technology social media problem i mean
you mentioned that there could be
intrinsically technological solutions or
regulatory solutions and neither one of
these
were things you're really optimistic
about i mean maybe say a bit more about
that i know that
that's also very much in the news these
days especially with facebook twitter
maybe a little bit less but uh facebook
youtube there are algorithms that drive
people to places where maybe we don't
want them to go and maybe that is
fixable
yeah i mean that so so this is a really
important issue and maybe we'll just
start start with youtube right is this
well-known effect that youtube uh
youtube sort of radicalizes and so you
know youtube pushes you toward more and
more extreme content we talk about this
in the book there's a little story where
jevin and his son are watching uh
watching the live feed from the
international space station on youtube
and then
on the sidebar all these flat earth
videos and
so you know so this comes back to the
constant a b
tests and the psychological experiments
that you know these these algorithms are
figuring out
that people move toward more extreme
content over time and they're
of course all of these algorithms are
being um
you know are optimized to maximize
engagement not
education or accuracy or anything else
like that so
you know i think definitely that kind of
algorithmic direction
is is really important and really
problematic i mean we see something
similar if you try to use
facebook or twitter to uh get a good
sense of uh what the
what the you know general uh zeitgeist
in the country is not just the zeitgeist
among the friends of a
you know an academic in seattle say uh
so i follow
people all over the country with
different opinions and things like that
but
you know twitter quickly learns that
when uh you know some of my right wing
follows who i don't necessarily tend to
agree with
post blinks i don't click on them so it
stops showing them to me
and so then i i i get pushed back into
my own
filter bubble if you will so i mean this
is where i think regulation could be
somewhat useful as i'd like to see
uh i'd like to see ideally
ideally it's sort of opt out but but but
even opt-in would be okay
i'd like to see people have a lot more
control over the content that they
actually see
on social media and things like this but
i'd like to see these
algorithms um you know the sort of
recognition that these algorithms are
not designed
to um move us toward this
uh extremely important uh
you know feature of of having an
informed electorate they're designed for
something else and given
that um and given this role these these
are playing essentially as
as major media companies um
we need to have a little bit more you
know we need to downplay the influence
that
that these algorithms are having so um
you know
i'd like to see if you opt in on twitter
you should be able to just see what your
follow the people that you're following
have posted in order
you know no no [ __ ] and
so with these kinds of things i think
would be would would be little steps
that would
that would move us in the right
direction i think they're they're they
don't
they don't trouble me in terms of sort
of first amendment
arguments i mean if you look back to the
origins of uh
of the fair and balanced doctrine from
the fcc prior you know until it was
killed under under reagan uh it was not
something about bandwidth limitation per
se
it was uh basically that it was a
synchronous democracy
was that people you have to have an
informed electorate and so we need fair
and balanced coverage of the issues that
matter
and so that was one of the other
criteria there was that the news
stations had to talk about relevant
things
um and uh so uh
i think that there's quite reasonable
precedent the way we think about
about media to say that you know another
synonym for democracy
is to have people able to get access to
the information they want instead of
being manipulated by these algorithms
that are able to run
non-stop experiments on them 24 hours a
day to maximize their own engagement
so that would be you know kind of the my
ideal there's these little
things you could do that would you know
chip away at the problem but would only
chip it away at the problem
you know it's like why do we allow uh
targeted political advertising on social
media this is
so dangerous you know i can i can you
know
target all of the uh you know i could
target all of the unemployed men between
35
and 45 in tuquela who have indicated
racist sympathies
um that's something we've never been
able to do before and more or less
trivial to do on
you know with social media advertising
and then once i do it the ad that i've
put out there is dark
in the sense that if i run a national
racist broadcast ad everyone sees that i
did it
but if i just push a message to these
400 people
um no one even knows that i did that and
i think that's a really really dangerous
thing we've got
very strong restrictions on political
advertising overall and so why we
continue to allow this i have no idea
i mean again a tiny piece of the puzzle
but these are the sorts of places where
i think regulatory solutions could be
useful
has there anything that you specifically
learned or changed your views about
since the covid19 pandemic hit i mean
you've been you've been out there on the
twitter front lines trying to set people
straight
uh is it more or less given that you're
an expert in both biology and [ __ ]
what you would have expected or has your
world been rocked by
how crazy things have been uh it has
somewhat been rocked because i really
did think we were all going to be on the
same
you know all going to be on the same
team when when this thing hit
and uh i thought that i mean you
remember what things were like after 9
11 you know like
you know everybody just felt like we're
all americans and we're going to put
these political divides behind and we're
going to unite we're going to solve this
problem
and yeah there i mean it wasn't you know
it wasn't blissful there was a lot of
you know uh
latent and not so late in racism that
came along with that and it wasn't all
good
but uh you didn't see the sort of
massive
hyper politicization of just every
aspect of the you know
the crisis that we're dealing with and
we did have this feeling of sort of a
common
uh goal and and and when you deal with
the pandemic of course
you may not want to admit it but we
really are all in this together because
of the infectious nature and the
of the of the disease and the fact these
things spread exponentially through
communities early on and so on
uh and yet we've completely failed to
address this as a unified country we're
unable to you know
not only are we unable to sort of mount
uh come up with
uh you know widely supported consensus
policies about what to do we can't even
agree on things like
uh whether this is killing one one
person in a hundred or one person in a
thousand we can't agree on whether or
not uh
you know school children are who uh who
get it or risk to their parents we can't
agree on whether masks help
um i definitely did not expect
that level of politization of the
science
and uh and and and you know i think
some of the ways in which that has has
happened has become quite interesting as
you as you look at what's changing about
the science we've
gone to you know in an effort to solve
this problem we've gone to
this you know most you know massively
open
science that we've ever tried where
everyone is posting raw data and
pre-prints
uh you know immediately people are
sharing all the code all the models are
up there for the most part there's some
exceptions that are sort of notable
but but uh you know it's it's been much
more transparent than it ever has before
at much earlier stages whether
waiting until everything goes through
peer review the discussion is taking
place on open boards on twitter on pub
pier
places like that instead of at
conferences and by by private email
so all of that discussion is out there
for the public to see and that you know
the piece that i kind of
hadn't really done an adequate job of
anticipating was that as soon as that
happens
and you have this thing super
politicized now every single paper that
goes out there
lands on one end or the other of a
political spectrum unless you exactly
split the
middle and sit on the rail and as soon
as that happens you know
that paper gets picked up by one side
and used as a cudgel to bash the other
side with
and so you know as soon as i release a
paper like if my paper is just trying to
estimate are not for this disease you
know the intrinsic rate of increase
um that paper is going to you know
benefit the arguments of one side and
and harm the argument so the other and
all of a sudden it just gets launched
into this
into this partisan debate that we as
scientists aren't used to i mean we're
completely used to the fact that you
know you think are not too and i think
it's three and i think you're an idiot
and i'm going to prove it
but it's there's no partisan tie to this
and and uh
and and so this new uh and similarly
people will
you know when when your evidence over
weighs mine people will just
take your side and now that this has
become polarized like this you know even
if your evidence overweighs
mine no one's gonna you know no one in
my tribe is gonna take your side anyway
because they don't wanna
risk anyone thinking that they're in
your tribe so
so this is the part that surprised me
and has been um
you know i guess in in april i just
found it enormously discouraging and i
think i've kind of
accepted it at this point and just you
know trying to think about how to work
in that environment now but it was yeah
that was a that was a real shock
i mean in addition to the sort of
political or identity
uh aspects of it i mean there's some
sort of purely scientific aspects that
are
curious to me i mean the idea of how to
model
uh the spread of an epidemic like this
and
there's even been maybe this counts as
politics but there's been little
squabbles like
economists versus epidemiologists and
who has the higher gre scores right
yeah that's right right right i mean
have we have we learned
have you learned anything about that
let's say has that surprised you
anything
i guess i've i already knew it but i've
learned you shouldn't hold george mason
against economics i mean that's one
thing i've heard
but uh um
you know i think that's actually been
more common you know i've done you know
i've been i've
i've always loved doing
interdisciplinary work and it's been
tremendous fun
and uh and it's a learned it's a learned
skill right and one of the one of the
key things to doing good
interdisciplinary work is
is not assuming the other person's an
idiot even when they sound like one
uh because you're probably not
understanding something but it is
something you have to learn and and
and you have to learn by by doing so i
think you have a lot of
people that are all of a sudden coming
from different communities working on
the same problem
or maybe they haven't done as much
interdisciplinary work in the past and
so you do see
more of these of these kind of clashes
whereas you know you know my own
experience
uh it's like so much fun you know
sitting down with a
with you know computer scientists and
having them tell me about game theory
from their perspective and you just
think gosh like
everything this brilliant person has
said for the last hour is wrong how can
they be so dumb and then you finally
eventually figure out what the what the
difference in assumption is you know
you're thinking about
expected case and they're thinking about
worst case and and
that clicks and then and then you know
then it all
and if you if you poison the well before
that clicks things you know
you don't move forward so i think i
think that's been the you know i think
that's been some of the struggle there
um and you know they're you know i don't
want to
uh to some degree i think there are
different disciplines that have
uh you know different cultures and
different uh
uh perspectives of their own superiority
um that may be you know we may be
bumping into a little bit of that too
but
uh i don't know and you already
mentioned the the fact that
some of the science is being done out in
the open um
but this is the there are issues so not
only is that being outdone out of the
open but then it's instantly politicized
like you said
but these are not new things because of
the pandemic they're
we're learning things we're seeing
things that were always there right it's
just
more of a reminder that science is kind
of messy and politicized and we should
keep that in mind when we evaluate
any bit of science i would i would
disagree i mean i guess the
the of course one thing i just want to
note before i do that
is that i'm acting as if this is a
surprise and all my friends in climate
science are just thinking like
you know you you poor innocent like
naive child like when they're
child yes and uh because they've been
dealing with this for
for for decades um and the rest of us
just kind of missed that and i missed it
even though
i was not um you know even though i was
actually involved in all the sort of
evolution wars stuff uh
in the in the early 2000s around uh
around intelligent design creationism
and all that and i still
still didn't you know anticipate this um
yeah but i think science uh i think
science is really not politicized in the
same
in the same way that we're that we're
seeing right now i mean i think that uh
you know there are there are
areas where as you move toward you know
applications you start to see
more and more of that but i think what
we talk about as being political
in in science is really a quite
different thing
um you know i take for example in my own
home discipline of uh evolutionary
biology mathematical population genetics
when we talk about sort of political
fights that often essentially come down
to battles between the
you know great grandchildren of sewell
wright and the great grandchildren
of r.a fisher right and it's and it's
absolutely remarkable actually if you
treat you
mark my uh phd advisor mark feldman
gives a great lecture where he sort of
traces back these ideas and
and you actually see that we really are
the great grandchildren you know having
the fights
continuing the fight between these two
between these two men
um and and and so that's really
politicized you know maybe it's like you
know
it's like goddamn guy is a selectionist
just through and through i just don't
understand how he could not see the way
that
epistasis works and so we talk about
that as political but it's a really
different kind of political than you
know
trump thinks hydroxyqualiquin will work
and uh and
and and damn the conspiracy that's
trying to cover it up no that's true
just just to clarify
i was using politicized in the former
sense more you know
nothing to do with right versus left
republican versus democrat red versus
blue but
there there are uh human attachments
whether they're you know or or
even just ways that you were brought up
as a scientist to pay attention to some
things versus another that are
not completely rational that have huge
effects over what we think is important
and how we go about doing even the most
removed science from uh political cares
in the real world
yeah absolutely i think that that's a
really good uh observation you know a
friend of mine jacob foster who's in
sociology
at uh at ucla and i spent a couple of
weeks
um trying to and not making a ton of
progress on this but trying to
understand whether an
adversarial model of science you know we
have an adversarial uh
model of uh of of justice in this
country where you've got a prosecutor
and a defendant you don't have sort of
consensus where everyone sits down and
decides whether the person is guilty or
innocent
um and to some degree science is more
adversarial than it's usually portrayed
in the public because you do have these
different schools and these different uh
you know political camps in the sense
you're talking about so we're thinking
about whether that could possibly
actually be a good thing
and i i think it probably is um and you
know
because it really uh sharpens the
uh the um
conflict among among uh
the data that we that we have you know
you you rarely have direct observation
of what you want to know
and so you have these various indirect
ways of trying to get at this
at this question and and where there are
conflicts there uh
if everyone kind of just agreed to
ignore them we might not uh
you know make the same headway as we do
when you have you know this school is
determined to prove that that school is
wrong and
and so forth i think that's i think
that's all good and well i think what's
what's been you know so discouraging
with the
with the pandemic is the way that
um
you just see a whole different level of
disinformation getting put out there i
mean
uh things that scientists would would
never do i mean i you know i may i may
really dislike the
the you know selectionists in population
genetics but i'm not going to make a
video where i
tell lies about them nobody does that
i'm just gonna try to write a paper that
shows that you know their their
their interpretation of the data is
stupid and uh
so so like like there's just a whole
different level and i'm certainly not
going to be you know
calling their universities and trying to
get them fired and and sending threats
and all the other things that public
health officials in the united states
are dealing with right now
so that's that's just sort of a
different
scale um it's like i don't i mean maybe
may and this may
just be you know a sort of uh
[Music]
appeal to the conventions that i'm
comfortable with
but uh in some ways i'm kind of saying
you know boy
people aren't fighting by the rules this
time
well emotions are running high and
stakes are high right so even if i
deplore it i i get it i'm not completely
surprised and even you know
far removed from those kinds of stakes
the the
the examples that are close to my mind
are like um
loop quantum gravity versus string
theory right
and yeah and i do work and i worry about
the
um even though i'm pretty
establishmentarian
on many physics issues i do worry about
a lack of diversity
uh viewpoint diversity here because
from a game theory perspective if you
think there's a 90 chance string theory
is right and a 10
chance that loop quantum gravity is
right every department is going to want
to maximize the chance that its people
are right so they will only hire string
theorists right and it
it's hard to build in that kind of uh
multiplicity of efforts
yeah a couple of my friends in the
philosophy of science have
written quite nice things about this in
particular kailyn o'connor and uh
and kevin zollman and they've written
about uh
about the um the value of epistemic
diversity
in in scientific research and they've uh
you know studied these kinds of
uh things where you have say epistemic
networks where people
share their beliefs with one another and
in fact if you have this
you know too tight of a community where
people quickly adopt one another's
beliefs you know basically everybody can
get off on the wrong track and science
doesn't proceed as fast
right and so on so i think that's you
know there's that's a you know a very
important observation and
and this has really been something i've
been very interested in the last five
years and then sort of got derailed by
by the by the whole covet crisis but
basically like
you know taking a hard look at the way
that science operates and looking at
what are our
institutions and our norms that we use
and and thinking about the way that
those norms and institutions create the
incentives that
that that shape our behavior and the
questions we ask and of course that
determines the outcome we get and so
there's
this direct tie from the structure of
these norms and institutions which
evolved more or less haphazardly
uh you know out of you know essentially
enlightenment ideas
uh and and western europe to to the
beliefs that we have about the world as
emerging from science right now and so
one thing we can do is we can go back
and look at the structure of some of
these
uh institutions whether it's things like
publishing or priority rule for credit
or
tenure system or whatever it is uh and
ask
how are these things affecting you know
epistemic questions about you know what
we believe to be true that is true what
we believe to be true that isn't what
you know what we what we don't know is
true even though it is uh
etc and and thinking about you know are
there ways to uh
nudge the system to uh to make it
function better
you know we see a lot of this going on
as people are trying to tackle the
reproducibility crisis right now and um
you know you could ask very similar
questions around issues such as uh
as viewpoint diversity yeah i mean and
the
the mentioning of the reproducibility
crisis brings up
the previous thing you mentioned about
how science is now being done in the
open
more and i know there's there's also two
sides to that
uh you know science is being done in the
open a lot more in including the fact
that
especially because of the covid crisis
people are noticing that there are
pre-print servers
right you can get scientific papers that
haven't yet been peer-reviewed
and on the other hand something even
though i'm a believer in peer review i
do
try to tell people that just because a
paper has passed peer-reviewed does not
mean it's correct
you still need to be a little bit
skeptical of it i mean do you think that
this
greater openness is improving science or
is it a danger cause i know there's a
lot of people who say
it's terrible to let the hoi polloi in
on all the speculations and preliminary
ideas that scientists had around all the
time
that's that's gatekeeping [ __ ] that
i'd completely disagree with that i mean
i agree but i'm not
it would be it would be you know you're
a physicist you know what
it does to science when you open up
pre-print servers it blew my mind the
first time i wrote a physics paper i
it's a paper on uh it's a paper on
network theory wrote it with postdoc of
mine martin rossvall
i was really excited about it i thought
it was i thought it was neat work and i
really hoped i could get it into a good
journal so that people would read it and
and give me some feedback on it martin
wasn't nearly as concerned about this
we posted it to the uh posted at the
archive
um and within a week every single person
that i wanted to read it had written me
back
you know unsolicited and had read the
paper and had
the comments that i was hoping to hear
or in some cases critiques i was hoping
they wouldn't you know that wouldn't
exist and so on but that was like
that was a revelation to me so you know
having pre-print servers and and and
and you know having the time lag between
putting an idea out there and it being
adopted by the rest of the community
being a few days instead of
a year is is enormous obviously
and i also think that you know this this
this notion of gatekeeping
is uh you know and and we shouldn't let
the public see what's going on behind
the
the walls of the ivory tower this is
also absolute rubbish
what we could do a better job of is
explaining how the whole process works
and if we do that then we have to hit on
the thing that you hit on as well which
is that
you know peer review is no guaranteer of
of uh
correctness either what i you know what
i think of peer review as
this we write about all chapter about
science and how it works and all this
stuff in the book but
you know what i think of peer review as
is i think of it as you know kind of
like burn-in in engineering it is
enriching for things
that are correct and interesting um
it's not guaranteeing that anything is
correct and interesting it's just taking
a bunch of the stuff that
isn't correct and a bunch of the stuff
that isn't interesting and throwing that
out
and you end up throwing out a little bit
of the stuff that is correct and
interesting but
that's the cost of of enriching the pool
of
stuff that you see and then of course
you've got this tier of journals from
the highly enriched
um to to the barely enriched and
and you can sort through all of that and
and the highly enriched maybe
enriching for not the things you want
and people complain about you know
most of the stuff in science and nature
is sensationalized
and so on and and that you know that may
be the case whereas most of the stuff in
cells may be enriched for being correct
but not being very interesting or
whatever
uh depending on your on your perspective
um
but i mean fundamentally that's what
peer review is doing um it's helping
improve the papers as well
and it's enriching the pools but it's
not you know it's it's it's not this
like seal of approval that
we um that it's been presented to the
public as unfortunately
all right final question going to be
completely unfair here i mean i know you
you begin your book by saying that uh
what is that what is it a sentence you
use you remember it
uh there's there's so much [ __ ]
probably
we are awash yeah the world's awash and
[ __ ] and we're drowning in the world
it's a wash in [ __ ] so um and we've
we've mentioned a lot of
techniques that people can use uh
offhandedly but like
is there the best piece of advice you
have
for you know we people on the street who
are awash in [ __ ]
to separate it out i mean is there like
one or two
uh pithy little things we can say or is
it
more that we just have to generally keep
our wits about us and try our best
now there are a few pithy things that
you can do um you know what one of them
is to just recognize
that uh that if something if some claim
seems too good or too bad to be true
it probably is and uh so so these are
the things that we're most likely to
share especially on social media and yet
they're the most likely to be wrong
i learned today only today that there's
a there's a law about this which
twinman's law for data analysis is that
any figure that looks interesting or
different is usually wrong
the more unusual or interesting the data
the more likely they are to have been
the result of
an error of one kind or another and this
seems
quite a reasonable law of data analysis
it's a law of media analysis as well i
think when you
when you think about it so that so that
would be one you know another thing i
really push people
uh on is you know especially in those
cases and if you care track things back
to the source
so you know the way one of the things
that emerges through
um you know through the social media
environment but we had even beforehand
it's just exacerbated is that you have
this sort of game of telephone where
you'll have a you know maybe you'll have
a
set of you know research studies that
are distilled into a scientific paper
that is uh written up in a medium post
that's picked up by the
new york times that gets tweeted about
um
and then and and then you see the tweet
and
so if the tweet seems too good or bad to
be true
start tracking back and and finding the
you know finding this
you know figure out for yourself what
the story is
so i think you know the most important
and the most important and that's this
is what we teach in the class
uh and the students get so excited you
know i'll have the students come in and
they'll say you know oh i saw this tweet
from nbc news
and then i tracked it back and it was it
was actually about this story and the
story came from this research paper and
you know what professor burgess for me
was [ __ ]
and uh which is so cool and
and done good well what it you know what
it
what it gets at for us is is a fear with
this class is that we
create a uh you know a community of
nilest
and and and cynics uh whereas what
we want to try to do is to show people
that despite
the uh you know [ __ ] prone world
that we live in
there is truth out there and you can get
to it
yeah that's a very good motto i cannot
possibly think of a better place to
finish the podcast on so
karl brookstrom thanks very much for
being on the mindscape podcast uh thanks
it was great to talk to you sean
[Music]
you